the best relationships i've seen are
people who want different things but
know how to want different things
together
because it's the things you have in
common that attract you and it's your
differences i think that keep
relationships really interesting
the problem is people have a very hard
time hanging in the tension of wanting
different things and knowing how to
navigate that
without defaulting into some type of
blame or shame or guilt
especially if someone's in a trauma
response because they're not in their
executive function ventral vagal system
their highest
best use of their nervous system they're
in a dysregulated state which over time
does cause a lot of damage to the
relationship
[Music]
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
episode 101.
in this episode i spoke with mastin kipp
this is an episode from russia when i
full on had kovid
was super stressed worried had to get
home couldn't get home because i'd covet
so i thought who else to talk to but
mastin kip
a number one best-selling author speaker
creator of functional life coaching for
people who are seeking rapid
transformation in their lives
he's been featured on the emmy awards
show super soul sunday and recognized as
a thought leader for the next generation
by oprah herself now i know how many of
you guys are oprah fans
so i figured this was a step in the
right direction
all jokes aside i think the only way to
survive in this insane life
is to listen to every type of healing
and psychological trick
and see what sticks what works i think
there's something to mastin's techniques
we discussed trauma functional life
coaching polyvagal theory
what it takes for a human to regulate
emotions trauma bonding the active
listening process
mdma parts work the importance of play
which is something my dad talks about a
lot and more
i even cried at one point thanks to
mastin very much for coming on
[Music]
welcome to my podcast thank you so much
for having me i'm very excited to be
here
very excited you might not be as excited
as me
i need a lot of trauma work this is
going to be very useful for me and
hopefully for other people as well i
hope so too
okay can we start off by you giving a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
sure and also before we do that you know
people hear the word trauma sometimes
they equate it something scary almost
like cancer
i just want to let everybody know that
trauma work is the thing that's going to
help you go the next level in your life
so if you want the next level in love
relationships your body finances
whatever health and wellness
trauma work is super important just want
to put that plug in there and that's
we'll talk about today
for me i used to be a music manager back
in the day um
i was in los angeles for many years
working with bands like corn limp
biscuit
linkin park and stuff like that and
through a very long series of events
realized that is not the path i want to
be on
and kind of reluctantly got into the
coaching space over many years i feel
like the universe like dragged me into
it
i had other plans um and i was never
really satisfied with
the answers i was getting i was i love
growth i love learning
very much like you and your family um
but i was never satisfied with a lot of
the results i was getting i grew up in a
science house my father's a phd in
biology would edit peer-reviewed
journals
and we had a really rigorous scientific
process growing up and when i would
question
you know different personal development
spiritual therapeutic modalities nobody
had
answers they just kind of had they had
like they had like philosophies
basically
and what i had noticed when i started
getting my own private practice is that
people would set a goal
but then not take the action to achieve
it most of the time
and after a lot of self-discovery with
myself and with my clients and no formal
training started to realize that people
had been through adverse experiences
that were impacting their goal
achievement
and i did not know that was called
emotional trauma i did not know anything
about
the nervous system i was just watching
people in my practice
and helping them you know resolve these
things and address these things
um transparently helping them know i
have no background or credentials or
anything like that but people
were getting results and then probably
let's say i've been doing this like 12
years
somewhere around 2015 i started getting
really curious what are the mechanisms
of action like
what the heck is happening in front of
me over the last six years
and that's when i really started to like
apply that science side and learn more
about the mechanisms of action regarding
the nervous system and what emotional
trauma really is and
how uh how things work inside the body
so i could speak intelligently because i
really want to make sure that we were
doing things that had efficacy and their
evidence their evidence-based approaches
and it looked like i was helping people
but i wanted to trust and verify and
then once i got into the
trauma space and in terms of like all
the science behind it it was just
verified everything i'd saw in private
practice
and then very quickly realized there is
a huge need for this work
in the world because you know the public
perceives therapy
more or less as looking at your past
which can be valuable
and coaching is moving forward but there
has to be a context of both of those
kind of things in your timeline
so that when you move forward in context
to what happened to you
it starts to makes make your behavior
currently make sense and so
that's why i created functional life
coaching and
that's a very brief summary of what i do
i've been on oprah super soul sunday
um which has been amazing and um
have really gone into the trauma space
really intensely the last 12 years
explicitly in our marketing the last
three years but we've always been doing
the trauma work
and um it's interesting because there's
a lot more interest in the topic now
which is cool
so yeah alternative health practices
seem to be gaining traction maybe partly
due to social media and the great need
for it
totally yeah and you know what's ironic
about that though is that like
the word alternative versus traditional
like like if you really think about like
are you veda
is traditional medicine and western
medicine is relatively new
so there's this kind of arrogance and
science that says until we
admit something into reality that it's
not real until human beings admit it
um and and that's just not the case and
so i would argue that the western
medical system has a
very important uh role in
uh the world but if anything it's
alternative to what has been around for
thousands of years and there's
i mean the peer-reviewed data on ru beta
goes back thousands of years right it's
got a lot of efficacy to it
and the same thing goes a lot of somatic
trauma work because human beings have
been experiencing trauma since we've
been human so we've had a lot of
practices over thousands and thousands
and thousands of years
to regulate the scientists are catching
up now
but um i i think what we're doing is
actually traditional and the western
stuff is alternative and there's a good
blend of two but um people just want
what works
and that's why i think we're talking
today to talk about efficacy and what
works
i'm very glad to have made that
distinction i agree
i think probably a good place to start
is just to describe
what is trauma sure it depends on who
you ask right so
basically one of the problems with the
space is that there isn't a unified
definition
and yeah you could go to the dsm-5 which
is the diagnostic
and statistics manual for mental health
disorders i would argue that the
definitions in post-traumatic stress in
that book
fall short of what trauma is um you can
look at samhsa
i mean there's lots of places the way
that i define trauma
as uh my credential as an nmd which is
not a medical doctor
um i say that kind of jokingly but it's
true because people think i'm a
doctor or something i'm not but the way
that i look at trauma is it's any
experience
experience of threat disconnection
isolation or immobilization so threat
disconnection
isolation or immobilization that results
in the chronic or ongoing
dysregulation of your nervous system
your endocrine system
um your you know your emotional body
your immune system your heart or your
spirit so if you're in a dysregulated
state or a non-optimal state
in your nervous system immune system
endocrine system
emotional body or physical health or
spirit
long term then there is some type of
trauma to look at
and that's how i define it and by that
definition i'm not sure i know anyone
who doesn't have trauma
and it's an important context to realize
it's not just some
egregious aggressive physical injury
that's maybe blunt force trauma but
trauma is
such a vast topic and depending on your
race ethnicity background gender
sexual orientation each person's trauma
is unique and different so there is no
one-size-fits-all approach
but our goal is to be an optimal state
for the most part most of the time and
if we're not there's usually
some type of trauma holding us back
so one experience could cause trauma in
one person and not bother another person
a hundred percent yes and we
people ask why is that right well you
look at what is the state of someone's
nervous system endocrine system and
immune system going into a traumatic
event
how secure are their relationships how
emo how much emotional proximity they
have to the people around them
do they feel safe when they go through a
traumatic event
what happens afterwards right is it is
it love supported is there an empathetic
witness
do they have a resilient system already
or is it pushed under the table not
talked about disbelief and gaslit right
so
it really depends so when we look at
post-traumatic growth versus
post-traumatic stress
a lot of it has to do what happens
before and after a specific event
because it's not
really the event it sounds like crazy
but it's not really the event that's
traumatizing
it's what happens afterwards and it's
how much outside
your resiliency or your your body's
ability to handle stress
that you go and different people
different things just like just like
weights right
arnold schwarzenegger when he's five
years old bench pressing 300 pounds
would hurt him
right but when he's later when he's
grown he has a lot more muscle
easy peasy um and so it really depends
on the state of your nervous system your
endocrine system immune system and your
relational supports before during and
after and so
and then also in america your zip code
far more than your genetic code
determines your lifespan
um and there are studies that show
within a few miles of each other
life spans uh you know ranging from 30
to 40 years longer
just on the other side of the tracks
because of the socioeconomic status so
there's a lot that goes into trauma
and why people have different responses
to it so it's a very nuanced topic for
sure
it's very nuanced yeah and complicated
for sure
this episode is brought to you by
superspeciosa
superspeciosa is a kratom company kratom
is a herb related to the coffee plant
the leaves are extracts from the leaves
have been used as a stimulant and a
sedative
it works on opiate receptors in the
brain so it's been used to treat chronic
pain
digestive ailments and aid in withdrawal
from opiate dependency
i always advocate for dietary changes to
enhance mood before anything else
diet exercise saunas avoiding
inflammatory foods and poison
but if you're still having trouble and
you've already tried super speciosis
cbd tincture they have high quality cbd
products as well
and you felt like it isn't quite what
you were looking for or even if you like
their cbd
but you also want to try something else
kratom might be for you kratom's great
for energy support
some people will use it as a substitute
for coffee or as a pre-workout
some people use it to manage stress to
help them relax
superspeciosia has different strains
this one's premium bali
bags of this stuff
the most important part in my opinion of
super specious kratom is its reliable
third-party lab tested
and approved under the american kratom
association's quality standards program
only natural kratom bags of it
no other ingredients remember because
this works on opiate receptors it can
cause dependence
if you overdo it take it all the time so
do your research
but i've been someone who's come off of
opiates multiple times from surgeries
and
wish i'd known about something like
kratom during that period
if you want to try some kratom and get
20 off go to get
super leaf dot com and use code mp
for 20 off that's get super leaf dot com
slash
mp promo code mp for 20 off enjoy the
rest of the episode
what happens to the nervous system when
somebody's traumatized
um well it depends um it depends on the
type of traumas and what
what ages are traumatized right so let's
talk about like a young child right
let's talk about maybe a five-year-old
right
so a five-year-old um you know we know
children um don't have a fully developed
autonomic nervous system obviously the
prefrontal cortex is not
happening a lot at that time i don't
know the hippocampus limbic system
has a lot more left to develop and uh
trauma most the time is relational so
it's someone close to you or someone
that you know who's doing something to
you it's also what's called
multi-sensory
so it's not like just a sound traumatize
you or a feeling traumatized you or an
image traumatize you or
smell traumatize you or a place
traumatized you it's a combination of
all those things
and so when we look at uh traumatic
events we have to realize they're
multi-sensory
experiences they're not thought of it's
not like reading a book traumatizes you
typically
it's an experience that traumatizes you
and you have
a nervous system that's not well
equipped for that experience and so what
happens is we brilliantly
push it away dissociate from it try not
to look at it
and then over time that lives in the
system
and what happens in the psyche is the
psyche parts of the psyche freeze at
that age
so you may have a five-year-old an
unconscious associated five-year-old
running your life in certain areas
wherever there's like a
and by the way it's got this can also
stack over time like a geological dig
so you have like a five-year-old that
makes a decision then it forms what
happens at a seven-year-old moment and a
thirteen-year-old moment a 22-year-old
now you're like 35 going like what the
hell is going on so it's a geological
dig to understand where those parts of
the psyche are there
and to recognize that what they're doing
is not a limiting belief
it's not something that's wrong with you
it's not a pathology it's an appropriate
response the amount of challenge that
you experience and the trauma that you
went through
and to honor the nervous system's
responses so we get
fractured and fragmented in our psyche
those parts get dissociated from
pushed down and repressed and then it
what ends up happening is we have what's
called a inflexible nervous system so
our ability to respond
to stress and stimulus our range
decreases
because we don't have this ability to
regulate this ability to
build new neural pathways to have uh you
know neuroflexibility and things like
that
because we're in these like traumatized
states and a trauma response is whether
they're
dissociative down regulated what are
called dorsal vagal
or immobilized responses where we're
depressed checked out
not paying attention to things avoiding
things or if it's more of a sympathetic
response which is anxiety stress
cortisol adrenaline
we kind of get stuck and frozen in these
two different states and it's really
hard to imagine something outside of
those realms and so
we start to think that life is just this
emotional state of these few emotional
states
and eventually becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy and
it can it can really start to you know
damage your nervous system endocrine
system immune system over time
and when you look at chronic illness
you'd be hard-pressed to find someone
who has a chronic illness that doesn't
have an
emotionally traumatic antecedent meaning
something happened traumatically first
that then informed the system to have a
chronic illness response because
a lot of times when someone has like for
example cancer you know it's not like
your thoughts give you cancer
but if you have a dysregulated emotional
state and a dysregulated immune system
because of trauma your system becomes
more susceptible to pathogens and
carcinogens right
and so chronic illness will a lot of
times illuminate areas of highest
susceptibility
and yes there are absolutely medical
protocols to follow
that have to be followed for sure
depending on what you have and
there's typically an emotional
antecedent to that that is correlative
if not
causal sometimes in chronic illness too
so a lot of things can go wrong when we
don't do our trauma work for sure
okay that's interesting i've been
delving more into
trauma and and that kind of work since i
got healthier
because i've realized i have a lot of
trauma i've been through a lot of
experiences especially being sick
seeing family members sick yeah and i
have states i'll get into where i'm like
my brain just leaves for a while yeah
and i
operate on in just go mode and
i've had concerns lately about what kind
of damage stress can do to the body
like it stops you from sleeping i've
noticed if i get really stressed
it'll upset my digestion it won't matter
what i eat but like i'll be nauseous i
won't want to eat and
if something hits you that hard and
starts causing physical problems
it's definitely something to start
looking into take seriously yeah and the
world's cutting edge functional medicine
doctors like know this
because ultimately people aren't going
to be compliant on a functional medicine
plan
if the trauma responses are there right
so they're starting to realize this
and and certainly with chronic illness
there absolutely are
correlations and i would say most of
time causations to the majority of
chronic illness responses
and um it's really about you know for me
chronic illness
or any type of mental illness um i say
that kind of
it's more like it to me it's not
post-traumatic stress disorder it's
post-traumatic stress response it's an
appropriate response to
what happened but whenever there's some
type of diagnosis
there's an opportunity to develop a
relationship there or there's an
underdeveloped relationship with that
part of your body
and so turning towards it noticing it
befriending it
can be a very important step not just
trying to um
to numb it and sometimes medication is
necessary to stay within a window of
tolerance but it's not like a long-term
fix typically
yeah i had a terrible experience with
long-term ss or i use
so yeah i'm not a big fan of those for
long term definitely
actual solutions uh so
say you've been traumatized by something
some experience you've had
and you get triggered enough that you
kind of disassociate
or you go into derealization or
something like that
are there easy steps to bring you back
to yourself
such a great question um yeah so
um what i'm about to say uh depending on
where people are in their path may they
may or may not like it so
um i think that the most important piece
of science to come out
probably since langley wrote the book on
the autonomic nervous system in 1921
uh is the polyvagal theory by dr steven
portis and i look at langley as like the
newton
of the nervous system like isaac newton
newtonian physics like okay cool we're
starting to understand how the world
works
what porgis has done dr porges has done
with polybagel theory is equivalent in
my opinion
what einstein did with relativity for
the nervous system like it's like a
major shift in upgrade
um and how we look at the nervous system
and in polyvago theory there's a few
tenants of
and polyvagal theory is the science of
safety and connection and regulation
right
and when we look at like what does it
take for a human being to regulate which
is basically your question right
we have to have co-regulation which is
togetherness
right and so this idea that i have to
work on myself or love myself enough
until or i have to get myself
out of something is a very more of an
avoidant response typically because
there have not been competent protectors
or people in your life
who are able to create safety and be
like a container for you to have
different emotional experiences
but the best way to regulate is
co-regulation which is not co-dependency
the difference between co-dependency and
co-regulation is that when you're in
codependent for uh
responses another person becomes your
only form of regulation like you need
the person to regulate which is an
appropriate response when you're a young
child because you don't have the anatomy
co-regulation basically says together
we're better
and when people co-regulate and they
have relationships they can share what
matters to them and be heard and seen
and listened to and validated
by the way not necessarily agreed with
on the facts
you can agree you can acknowledge
someone's emotional state and hear their
emotional state
and not need to agree on the facts and
still be an effective listener
um but that co-regulation is like such a
biological imperative
for us and so when we're checked out
dissociated
um if you can create safe relationships
where someone can check on you and for
me when i'm in that state i don't know
if you watch stranger things
but i call that the upside down i'm in
the upside down oh my god
i don't know how many people do that but
when i had sorry to interrupt
when i was in horrible ss or i
withdrawal
i was watching stranger things and i was
like that is what my life feels like
that's exactly what it feels like that
horror and darkness and grayness
yeah so yes yeah it's a lot and it's
it's nice to let certain people in your
life know and when i'm truly in the
upside down
like i'm not verbal i can basically only
blink
um because i'm so just like gone right
and so people ask me you know specific
people in my life are you on the upside
down and i'll just kind of blink and
they know that that's like a yes right
um and it's important to have you like
that in your life now if you don't have
people like that in your life
the next best thing is is that baby just
really it sounds really basic but we
want to recap to the breath and the body
and like literally just like touch your
body and ask yourself where is my body
right now in time and space
because when we're checked out and
dissociated or depersonalized
um basically we're not feeling our body
we're not it's affect right affect is
emotional data coming up from the body
to the brain
it's so intense that we're kind of
checked out from it if you don't know
how you feel in your body the term for
that's called alexa thymia
and it's important to start to just pay
attention to your body and like
literally place a hand there
to reach out and let somebody know how
you're feeling who's a safe person
it sounds really basic but when you're
in that type of state that you're
talking about there
isn't a lot to do because you don't have
a lot of energy
and just like literally like someone's
hand on your hand can be so valuable
and the majority of mental health
protocols and personal development
protocols and spiritual protocols the
message on some level is
you have to self-regulate or will
medicate you or
you have to self-regulate or you're not
enough you have to self-regulate or
you're not spiritual enough or you're
not developing enough but the science
and political theory is so clear that
to improve self-regulation we need
better co-regulation and that's like a
primary
primary thing for people to realize is
that we need each other
and that's um for people who are more
avoidant uh they're like
ugh for anxious people they get really
excited you know you're very excited
about that
um but we do need each other to better
regulate and for me what i've done
is i've gotten proactive in my life
because when i'm in the state like
you're talking about
it's really hard for me to reach for
support so i set up support ahead of
time
so that i don't have to reach for it
when i'm in that state
it's already like on the books for like
a thursday i have like consistent
coaching or therapy or body work or
whatever
so that i know that i have these touch
points throughout my day and week so
that i'm not
if i get into one of those dissociated
states
i know i have something coming up
they'll help me co-regulate and get out
of it so i set that up when i'm in a
better state and then it helps me not be
as down for as long either but most
people don't do prevention they have to
do it when they're down and then
learn from it but if you're if if you
want to get out in front of it having
some type of consistent support in your
life that's scheduled is super important
too
okay that makes a ton of sense to me i
think a lot of the people i've brought
on the podcast are like you know fix
yourself
you have to reach this certain level
then you're ready for a relationship so
that you avoid this codependency thing
but
we're social creatures right i i so does
it see
to me that's just someone anyone who's i
used to say that by the way people who
say that
um are terrified of being hurt again
terrified of losing themselves in a
relationship again terrified that if
they find a relationship that they can't
have love
or they can't have a business or success
because they collapsed last time
while the other person collapsed what's
true is
trauma happens in relationship and
healing happens in relationship
and there may be some baseline of like
self-love that might be important to
arrive to but the honest truth is in
relationship
specifically romantic relationships but
certainly professional too
the highest purpose of them is to be a
caretaker of each other's trauma
and to be a place to regulate not a
place to go to disregulate
each other and your partner
will absolutely if you choose wisely
love parts of you that you could never
love on your own because it's a
relational dyad it's a relational
experience it's something that happens
together
so um that i love myself until thing is
a
very classic avoidant perfectionist
mindset
that has an underbelly of a lot of fear
of either collapse or
some type of dysregulation again which
by the way can only be fixed in a
relationship not on your own
okay okay so then here's a question for
relationships
what happens if you and someone you're
either in a romantic relationship or
close with what if you guys
experience a traumatic experience
together and
then the experience of this other person
is now traumatizing
yeah so that's very so i work with a lot
of uh
specifically men who are in relationship
with a woman who has you know a ptsd or
cptsd diagnosis i hate the word i hate
complex
see i hate cptsd is the worst the worst
name for something what is that
it's just complex ptsd which means you
have multiple traumatic experiences
so like it's worse yeah but it's like
it's like the people that name this [ __ ]
it's like it's like
it's like it's not that complex and like
panic attack like why do you call it
panic attack like just saying a
pancreatic makes you want to have a
panic attack
like i just think the names of these
things are like the worst um
and like saying something is complex
like in and of itself makes it more
complex it needs to be a
different story but i work with people
who maybe one person has more trauma
than the other person
and what you're talking about is more
vicarious trauma
and or trauma bonding and it really
depends on
um the type of support you have right
because you can work through those
things because when you're in a
way if someone has vicarious trauma
meaning the person that they're in a
relationship with has a lot of trauma
and it impacts the other person there's
a lot of opportunity for growth there
you need to work
with a practitioner who understands
they're not just trauma informed they're
trauma trained and specifically in the
context of
helping people work through
developmental or early childhood trauma
as it's showing up in adult
relationships because any relational
issue that comes up in my opinion and
the data seems to support this
is some type of unresolved thing from
childhood that's
here to be healed and so when you look
at relational ruptures
or relational issues you know
relationships grow
just like muscle with micro traumas and
they rupture and then there's a repair
process right so that's how
relationships grow
so um that is absolutely a time to do
the work and you want to make sure that
you're with someone who understands
how to regulate their own nervous system
and then what we're really talking about
is differentiation which is
being fully yourself and your partner
being fully themselves in a relationship
but you're in a relationship
individuation is when you break up or
get divorced
and differentiation you know people get
divorced they say
well we have irreconcilable differences
and people say well we want different
things so we shouldn't be together
but the truth is the best relationships
i've seen are people who want different
things but know how to want different
things together
because it's the things you have in
common that attract you and it's your
differences i think that keep
relationships really interesting
the problem is people have a very hard
time hanging in the tension of wanting
different things and knowing how to
navigate that
without defaulting into some type of
blame or shame or guilt
especially if someone's in a trauma
response because they're not in their
executive function
ventral vagal system their highest best
use of their nervous system they're in a
dysregulated state which over time
does cause a lot of damage to the
relationship so that's a little bit of a
verbose
answer but i hope it was at least
somewhat uh
somewhat helpful that that was
uh okay so say say you're in a
relationship with somebody
and you're still at the point where you
guys trigger each other
okay what's the first step there
if it's just like you're so triggered by
each other it's just stress as soon as
you guys speak
yeah um well okay you need other people
to like
yeah work on yourself and then mend that
relationship or what
in my opinion yes so great question um
so okay so a couple of things polyvagal
theory one of the other intents of
polybagel theory is this idea of
neuroseption
and neuroception is your neuro is
nervous system septions perception so no
reception is the
your nervous system's perception of your
environment right and it's mostly below
the neck
and what happens is we get triggered
before we know we're triggered
yes right and so like first of all
you're never gonna not get triggered
it's gonna happen
it's more about how fast you notice it
and when you notice it what do you do
right and the more regulated you are
the better able you are to handle
triggers now triggers are going to
happen
but ultimately i think the most
fundamental skill set in a relationship
is the ability to listen to somebody
else
set yourself aside and try your best to
tap into what they're thinking and
feeling
outside of what you think is going on
because when someone
really feels heard and validated and
seen
the majority of fights tend to stop the
problem with that
is that that's not really a common skill
set and
most people have such a lack of
reciprocity like their tanks are so
empty once they've gotten to that point
that nobody wants to go first and be a
listener because
they think if they listen that they're
not going to get their needs met so if
you can start to cultivate
a process of active listening which we
can talk about what that looks like
um and actually hear somebody else
without trying to fix them without
trying to change them without trying to
pathologize them or be their coach or be
their psychologist right and just
literally take in what they're saying on
an emotional level
um many relational problems get resolved
because most people just want to be
heard
um it's not a and especially if you're a
masculine person
talking to a feminine person it's never
about logistics
okay it's never ever about the logistics
that could be a man or a woman gay
straight lgbtqia plus
mass and feminine of course are energies
um but uh it's
very rarely is it about the facts and
mostly it's about emotional connection
and when you're fighting and triggered
you're both missing each other
emotionally basically
both asking the other person to hear
them and no one's able to do that the
goal is one person should go crazy at a
time
in a relationship hopefully
okay so you talked about active
listening as in listening without
immediately trying to fix all the other
person's problems
is that what it is kind of yeah so in
the in the most ideal setting with
active listening right you have a
process
um i learned this process from dr ellen
bader at the couple's institute and she
called and she's
like so good at what she does but
basically you have
um actual process and protocol for
emotional conversation so it's not just
like
right before bed everyone's about to be
asleep was like is now a good time to
talk
like that's not that's not the goal
right or like in just
right when someone's leaving or whatever
you want to actually schedule time and
you want to come to that conversation
in a time that's most wriggling for both
people where hopefully you're
well fed have good blood sugar levels
low inflammation maybe you just came off
a massage or acupuncture or something
you're in a good
regulated state um and then you have
roles
one person is someone who's gonna share
right
and i'll be the initiator who's like i'd
like to have an emotional conversation
and then the other person is what's
called um uh the listener
or the inquirer who's going to do the
listening
and ask questions and those are the
roles that you're in right so you're not
going to switch
because what happens is one person
starts to share
and that triggers the other person all
of a sudden they go right into sharing
their [ __ ] and like both people
basically um end up uh talking over each
other if you think about it right like
this green juice
right the juice inside this container is
more feminine
and the container is more masculine
right so what you're setting up is a
process
where one person is the container and
one person is the juice or the person
who's sharing emotionally
and what you basically do is try to
stick to one topic one
not like 50 000 things one topic at a
time
and you start to share slowly because
what happens is
especially if there's like a lot pent up
in there
you might say well i want to talk to you
today about last week when you brought
home the almond milk i really wanted to
be coconut milk or whatever it is right
um and when that happened i felt blah
blah blah blah and by the way your
sister and then
now the topic changes like we don't want
to do that right we want to stay on one
topic at a time and go slower
like one to two minutes of sharing that
allows the other partner to then listen
and go
okay so what i heard you say is when i
brought the almond bill back and not the
coconut milk you felt really
missed because you know because and for
you coconut milk is important because
the recipe
blah blah blah oh my god if i were you i
would feel really angry or
whatever right and you take a moment to
acknowledge that moment
but here's the magic question you asked
the question
okay but did i miss anything because a
lot of times when someone recap
something they're not going to say the
right word
the right feeling or the other person
might have more things coming up that
they didn't realize so that did i miss
anything
helps you not have to recap perfectly
and someone could say well what you
missed is i was really mad at and then
all of a sudden something else comes up
and when that starts to happen both
parties are learning at that time
right about what's happening within that
and the person who's sharing and you
basically repeat that process
like well so i heard you say was you're
really mad because actually the almond
milk had carrageenan in it and it's
really
bad for your digestion and like it's
like i don't even care about your health
because you know how much ibs
all this thing starts to happen right
and then eventually you say did i miss
anything and eventually the answer is
no and then you do your best to recap
again well if i were you i'd feel this
way that way
you know i would really be upset almost
like your partner doesn't care about you
because you know how much trouble you've
had with your ibs now what you spend on
doctors and all
all this stuff right just making up a
scenario in my head um
and then you like let it rest for a
minute and you don't make decisions in
that state you
just listen you don't need to agree on
facts that like someone's an [ __ ]
because they brought home
coconut milk instead of almond milk it's
more like what this person is going
through emotionally
and it's really important not to decide
when you're sharing emotions
right and then at a time in the future
whether it's right away usually not but
usually another time future you will
then switch roles
and the other person can start to share
what's happening emotionally and
again we're not agreeing on facts we
don't need to agree on a fact
we want to connect emotionally about
what was someone's internal experience
and what was the impact
of someone's behavior on them and what
you don't want to do is you don't want
to explain yourself
because when you explain yourself well i
did that because
you know yesterday i just you know my
friend was talking about almond milk
like
you don't want to explain yourself
because when you explain yourself you're
still
missing the other person and the impact
that your behavior had on them
so whether or not you had good
intentions there was still an emotional
impact and what you want to address in a
real great active listening session
is addressing the emotional impact that
behavior had irregardless of intention
because this is not a court of law
and we're not trying to figure out the
difference between first degree murder
and manslaughter right now
we're just trying to listen to like how
did my behavior impact you no matter
what i intended
and that's a really important thing and
when people are able to do that
awesome stuff happens it's a very
difficult skill set especially if you've
been in a relationship for a while
there's a lot of triggers there which is
why
you know getting a couple therapists
who's trained in that process from the
couple's institute might be a good first
step for sure because um
i've seen like you know couples where
like a girl the female might be like in
a heterosexual relationship
like the example i just gave well when
you you know you brought home the almond
milk i really wanted coconut milk and it
really upset me because my body or
whatever
and then it's like cool man what'd you
hear her say and what he says is well i
heard her say is i'm a piece of [ __ ] and
an awful husband
and like that's not what she said right
so it's just it's funny not funny just
like
see how bad or good people are actually
able to take in their partner and listen
and it's a presence is everything that's
so important that's great
that's that's very helpful that's pretty
easy so if you're in a relationship with
somebody
or or not necessarily romantic
anybody and you guys yeah anybody you
guys set each other off
set aside a time during the week calm
down prior to that
have one person address one subject
that's bugging them
and that could be something that's
traumatized them right sure yeah slowly
and then have them talk about how it
made them feel and then you reiterate
back to them
potentially how it made them feel yeah
you what you try to say
you try to say their words so like
classic nlp is called mirroring right so
you try to mirror their words and use
their language right
so if they said i felt upset don't say i
felt angry
right yeah i felt upset yeah and that's
not inauthentic right that's just like
caring about someone in their wording
and then you also say and if i were you
i would feel x y and z
does that make sense and someone like oh
no i don't feel that way i feel this way
oh wow what did i miss in that right the
what i miss part is so valuable
because it that you don't have to be a
perfect listener you can like let
yourself off the hook for like for that
especially if you're if the person goes
is going really quickly you're gonna be
like well slow down hold on a second let
me just see if i can get this part right
first because people just
unload sometimes and there needs to be a
little bit of container
a little bit of container and limits and
boundaries on the conversation otherwise
someone i've seen people go off like 15
minutes like how the [ __ ] do i recap
that
it's like it's impossible you know
[Music]
okay that's really cool so you can use
your relationships as
therapy using those guys yeah
theoretically right to regulate for sure
yeah
great okay um you mentioned the couple's
institute
a therapist from the couple's institute
so what is the couple's institute and
how how would you identify a good
therapist yeah uh
so i'm so such a loaded question um
so number one the number one thing i
want to tell you is that
in today's day and age people are
modality obsessed and drives me crazy
right i get like madison what do you
think about mdma what do you think about
psilocybin what do you think about
ayahuasca what do you think about
neurofeedback we think about brain
spotting fill in the blank whatever the
modality is i don't give a [ __ ] what it
is there's so many modalities right cbt
dbt emdr
eft i mean there's so many things right
and it's like
it doesn't matter i don't care about the
modality because the first
and most important treatment in any type
of personal development is safety
between you and the practitioner so if
you don't feel safe then no modality is
going to work
okay and even when you look at the map
studies that midhoffler and doblin are
publishing on psilocybin and mdma
they perceive mdma as
making the therapy better not as the the
protocol itself
right so if they're not saying mdma is
doing this work
what they're saying is the therapy is
enhanced
x percent the p value is this lower much
lower
because of the mdma right and there are
specific protocols that go into place
there
so the number one thing that you want in
a practitioner relationship is a
safe connection and the practitioner
needs to earn that
from you you don't have to just give
someone your trust because they're a
[ __ ] therapist okay as or it's coach
or whatever you they the practitioner
has to create the container of safety
number one number two i always like to
ask my practitioners like tell me about
like your
not just your credentials but like
what's your continuing education like
when was the last time you were like
what are you what are you up to what do
you care about what are you learning
about
i like to work with people who
understand polyvagal theory who
understand
some version of attachment theory uh who
have probably at least know who bessel
vander kulk is and have read the body
keeps the score like if you're not in
that world like i'm not
really interested in working with you
personally but that dyadic safety is so
important so if someone says
well i had a bad time with emdr
typically what they really mean is that
therapists i didn't feel safe with
and therefore emdr was a bad experience
and something like were you talking
about umdr was amazing
they probably felt really safe with
their therapist or their coach right
so you want to look at that safety and
then you want to understand like what
their background is
and depending on what you need different
therapists or coaches
are contextually appropriate couples
work specifically is so complex and
there are lots of couples therapists out
there but just because you're an lmft
does not mean you're good
licensed manager and family therapist
does not mean you're very good because
couples work is so
hard it's so hard right so dr ellen
bader
at the couple's institute specifically
specializes in picking a developmental
approach meaning
what happened in your and your partner's
history that's creating this conflict
how do we help you guys differentiate to
become two holes
together which is very difficult to do
and they also specifically focus on
entrepreneurial couples
so that because when there's
entrepreneur entrepreneurial couples or
like the stress of
what we go through all day every day
especially if you're in partnership with
that person or
have any any type of business
affiliation with that person
it's so complex and if you really think
about it how many well regulated in love
couples are there that are highly
successful
entrepreneurially very small number of
people
right um like it's easier to get a
billion dollars and go to mars than it
is to have be in a well-regulated
relationship
at that level right um and elon musk if
you ever hear the sound of my voice
please do not pick people are
traumatized to mars and not spread human
suffering to other planet okay um
okay please please please but like it's
very complex
it's very complex um what we're talking
about and so
but you have to go to someone who has
produced the outcome that you want
and dr bader's work when it comes like i
mean yeah hendricks is great
gottman's great they're all great but dr
bader and she's unfortunately she does
not have a big enough ego to like put
herself out there and to market herself
but she's like to me the couple's
institute's like one of the best places
in the world if you want couples
counseling
that's good to know okay thank you
let me see where does that lead me you
listed you're like
people ask me about all these questions
mdma therapy psilocybin yeah
it's like that cuts off like 40 of my
questions
we can talk about the efficacy of those
things for sure but it's not where you
start you know
i yeah i don't i think you covered what
i wanted to ask what i wanted to ask
was does mdma improve therapy and you
said
it depends on the therapist yeah and the
season setting like if you if you go
read the map studies right
um seen in setting is so important right
meaning like the environment of like
where the therapy is
they also have integration or prep
sessions then they have
you know a mdma session with integration
sessions
and then another one and they do that
with different types of protocols
depending on what the
patient or client is going through but
the efficacy
of mdma is well verified it's on the
cusp of fda approval
they're in phase three clinical trials
right now and they're they're very very
close
to fda clinical trial or fda approval
the first psychedelic to get fda
approval of course is ketamine
and people have already been benefiting
that from that tremendously but
again it's the relationship that matters
first and
if you look in the map's history right
this is public information
there was one instance i think in the
phase two clinical trials where
a um some of the therapists were married
couple
um who are facilitating some of this
stuff and the connection was so strong
between the male partner and one of the
clients ended up having
an affair because of the connection and
so if you're going to get into
ayahuasca psilocybin mdma psychedelic
world
stuff okay like first of all please do
not work with a shaman who went to peru
once and says he's a shaman for god's
sake okay please don't do that
right no cuddle puddles allowed we're
not into like let's just touch each
other and be naked and like none of that
[ __ ] okay
we're not doing that right we gotta be
in a sacred
safe environment okay because the
ayahuasca or the mbma or whatever
is not the agent of change it's your
psyche and the therapeutic relationship
with that
with that substance aiding
and expanding your window of tolerance
it helping you access memories that
weren't accessible before
and creating temporary neuroplasticity
so that you can de-personalize trauma
and view it through the lens of your
prefrontal cortex versus being so
associated with your limbic system like
there's a lot of beautiful things that
can happen
and i've heard horror stories um too so
it's not the drug
itself it's not the the thing itself
it's the scene setting
and the therapeutic relationship that
matters most
okay that that totally makes sense
awesome
what what happens if you've gone to a
number of therapists and you've had
bad a bad relationship with them
multiple times and now the idea of
therapy is kind of triggering yeah um
i don't want to come off sound like i'm
against therapists because i have
therapists i love therapists um
so it's kind of like when you're i like
to put everything back to dating even
though you don't
you don't date your therapist but people
understand dating usually pretty simply
right so it's like if you've dated the
same guy or girl in different shoes
five or six times you have to ask
yourself why do you pick that person
right and there are people who will pick
therapists who they know will either
just let them talk
right or on some level they don't feel
safe with because it's actually a
subconscious way of not moving forward
right and i did that for a long time i
got to a point where i realized
i'm not making progress in therapy i'm
talking the whole time holy [ __ ]
i'm smarter than my therapist right so i
had to go find people who could like
hear me do my thing and be all whatever
charismatic
excited taker energy that i bring and
they're like yeah actually massey you
know what and then like
house of cards falls yeah right so you
have to ask yourself if you're really
committed to change
and also it's about presencing in your
body do you feel safe with this person
just like in a relationship right do you
actually feel safe with this person and
that gets back to your own interception
which is your ability to perceive what's
happening inside your body
and how aware of it you are and you know
like
go a little slower like test them out
ask some questions push back like
therapists
and coaches transform coaches are not
god right
they're usually pretty good but just
because someone's a therapist does not
mean that
they're good at what they do like they
mean it means they're a great student it
does not mean they're a great
practitioner
i didn't consider that before so you
could actually poke around in their
background
ask questions gain some trust 100 yes
100
yes yeah without that trust it's like
it's how could you how could you
possibly reveal things
you know it's not it's not it's not it's
not appropriate for sure
and anyone who's offended by that like
that's a red flag right there get out
yeah okay fair enough how can you tell
the difference between a trauma response
and healthy fear of something
um i would argue they're both trauma
responses
because if you think about it everything
is kind of a trauma response right like
even like the skin that we have
right is a trauma response because we
had to develop skin because
we needed to have some type of like
boundary between our organs
and the world right so the question is
does it take you
out or not right because everything has
a level of trauma and especially if
you're growing right if you're growing
personally professionally in a
relationship
you're going to be in a tension zone
like tension is like where you're going
to live most of the time right how do
you grow muscle time under tension right
micro trauma so like micro trauma when
you're training that's trauma response
too
the question is does it take you out or
not right and
am i living in a trauma response that's
preventing my future from being bigger
or not
um and what what i typically do is is if
i'm in a response i'm not gonna go
is this intuition or is this trauma i'm
gonna go literally take my hands and go
okay where do i feel that in my body
i'm gonna go like maybe right to my
diaphragm i'm gonna bring my awareness
there i go all right
what am i feeling oh [ __ ] that's like a
panic okay great awesome cool and then a
great question how old do you think i am
how old do you think i am and the answer
is like three okay cool
awesome what are you trying to keep me
safe from oh that time when
your parents left the babysitter
whatever right like all that stuff
starts to come up right
it's like cool thank you for being here
um
do you know how old i am now the answer
is usually no right and i've
i've done this in my parts and they
still don't always know hold on i've not
told them a hundred times right
because there is this automatic response
it's like cool i got this now like you
want to come with me
like you want to move forward with me
right um and and
typically when you befriend it and you
listen to it and you talk to it it tends
to chill out because it's
usually there's a response in the body
that's wants your attention
and instead of pushing it away like
maybe your parents did you pause
you don't say how do i let go of this
how do i do hole traffic breath work to
make you go away
because a lot of these like personal
development modalities
um make parts not unwelcome right so
it's not that they're bad i love all the
modalities
but if your approach with the modality
is this part of me
is not welcome here how do i make it be
quiet
it's going to speak louder eventually so
instead of like
trying to breathe it away or whim hop it
away which again i do all that stuff
but we want to go towards it and like
literally start to listen to that part
of our body go what's up
and not called a limiting belief because
there's no such thing as a limiting
belief it's a survival response
and we say cool oh you know what i'll
take that into consideration you know
what
just this morning actually i was doing a
meditation and i felt it in my solar
plexus
and i was like why are you here like i
should be fine it was like mastin
don't lose your self-respect in the
specific situation i was going through
right now and i was like
i feel like i respect myself but this
part was like i'm really worried that
you're going to lose your self-respect
again
right because you're going to be in this
relationship where you're giving more
than you're receiving
like i was like oh thanks for that okay
cool i'll be on the lookout for that and
all of a sudden
it relaxed right and it was like this
part
wanted me to just go hey don't forget
and it's not like there's nothing wrong
with that i was just like
cool awesome thanks for the information
i pursue with my day right so that level
of befriending is super important
if we push things away that's when they
get louder and things tend to get
uh much worse so that befriending
turning towards something is a much more
uh
efficient process for sure and you know
internal family systems therapy
is probably one of the best documented
processes for how to do that
we don't do internal feminisms in our
practice but we do do parts work in a
different way but ifs is a great therapy
to look into if you're looking for like
peer reviewed data on the efficacy of
what i'm talking about
there's a bunch of it out there on that
modality
okay i'm going to need to prod into that
a little bit
internal family systems therapy yes by
dr richard schwartz he was a family
therapist who studied with virginia
satir
who basically realized that there's also
it's not just an external family but
there's also an internal family
um and so he was he's someone who's
really made parts work
um and there's many different ways to do
parts work like ifs is one modality
um but uh he's one he he really he was
he worked with a lot of like uh
multiple personality or dissociative
identity disorder patients
and started to realize that like
everybody has multiplicity in their
psyche we all have different parts of
our personalities right
it's actually not a pathology to have
multiple parts of our personality
the problem is they don't know about
each other they're not introduced to
each other they don't get along that's
when we get ambivalence internal
conflict
and so ifs is one great modality to do
parts work
uh functional coaching that we do uh
also awesome the difference is they have
a way more peer reviewed studies than we
do at the moment which is why i always
like to point people towards efficacy
and not just my [ __ ] um but parts work
is
is real and valid and works and the more
you turn towards it versus try to
escape it the better okay
you might have to delve into what parts
work is a little bit okay um
so when you're triggered um so parts so
we have we have
every emotional state that you're in is
a different part
of your psyche okay and when you get
triggered or when you're happy those are
different parts
and so you know you probably feel
anxiety differently in your body than
you would feel depression different than
you would feel
joy different than you would feel
frustration those are all different
parts and so what happens is usually we
focus on negative emotions but you can
do it for positive emotions too
let me rephrase that uncomfortable
emotions there's no such thing as a
negative emotion
bad mass then okay um just uncomfortable
emotions
um and comfortable emotions so if you
have anxiety right it's like cool where
do you feel that in your body well
usually it's like somewhere
you know chest or throat or somewhere it
depends on where it is for somebody we
go there and we go cool
how old do you think i am and the answer
is typically not how old you are right
now
and it's like what do you try to keep me
safe from and then the answer is you
know based on your history
now sometimes when you bring an
awareness to a part it either gets quiet
which is another part trying to keep it
quiet or you like
[ __ ] hate the stress and all of a
sudden in a different part of my body i
had this like anger towards this part
which is another part
right it's like whoa okay how old do you
think i am and maybe we're a little bit
older now maybe we're a teenager who's
pissed off at this part right for not
speaking up right
right and all of a sudden it's like oh
my god i'm so sad why
because every time i get angry right i
just blow up my relationships those are
three different parts we've just
discovered
right and so it's like and they don't
know about each other and they don't get
along and they're all different ages
so what we have to start to do is
understand that like we have all these
different parts that are happening and
the part that wants to run the show
in ifs is called the self you in
polyvagal theory it's called your
ventral vagal system spiritual
traditions we'll call it your spirit or
your soul
but you can access self energy very
quickly um uh
if someone who knows what they're doing
and ultimately what we want is when you
start to feel
compassion and love or understanding
towards other parts and what they've
been through and the burdens that
they're carrying
that's that self energy that starts to
emerge and what you want to do is start
to
let that part lead these other parts
because there's a term called being
parentified which is usually when you're
younger if
you don't have competent parents you end
up kind of like taking on more of a
burden than you should have
and you become a parentified child who's
taking on more responsible than they
should have
that then gets multiplied inside your
body where there's all these different
parts of your psyche that take cook on
more than they should have
never having that internal access to
self-energy or to your spirit
um to actually guide them and so
ultimately
what we want is we want to have all
those parts be voiced understand how old
they are to start to get along and
understand each other
and to be introduced to the self or to
the soul or to the spirit
to let that part of you drive and that's
like really a
valuable process because when you're in
that so it's called richard schwartz
calls itself leadership
when you're in self leadership then like
those parts can come up and actually
have a conversation with that soul cell
for that
self energy and start to be validated
and understood
versus like trying to run the show and
when they start to realize that the self
is competent and able and will keep you
safe
they start to chill out and do other
things with their time and energy
besides drama and conflict and stuff
like that because mostly parts want to
have fun
and not [ __ ] up your life or slow you
down but if it's going to result in
injury they're going to speak up really
loudly and so it's a it's a process
and it takes time to wire that
connection right because our neural
pathways have to be created
but um ultimately the sort of parts work
101
i think i said a lot of stuff really
quickly but that's basically what parts
work is and it's really it's a beautiful
process and
it takes a lot of the onus off the
therapist to be this regulator or the
coach should be this regulator
because you're always turning someone
back into their their internal sense of
agency and self
which is usually more valuable than um
you know having to always go to them for
some answer or something like that
that's fascinating okay that's that's a
rabbit hole
that was that was really cool and it
totally makes sense like when i get
um i'm pretty i'm pretty stuck in fight
fight or flight
and i've been stuck in that for like i
got out of it when i got healthy and my
ssri withdrawal went away
then my mom got cancer then my dad
almost died and it was just like and so
now i'm stuck in it and i'm totally
aware that i'm stuck in it so
small situations will you know shock me
and then my brain will
go over here and be like nah and then it
takes 18 hours until i'm like [ __ ]
finally that's over yeah but i have
noticed that when i get that fear
response
which is somewhere like here if i get
that fear response
i get angry instantly because that's how
i've learned to
kind of cope with being scared was well
being scared and
like shocked isn't useful at least being
angry gets you to do something
right but it's not you know working its
way out or anything i haven't heard of
this part we can do a little version of
that right now if you want i don't know
what you feel comfortable okay
i'm not doing but we can we can try it
um okay
so do you know where you feel that fear
in your body
yeah it's in a couple places i get
really cold arms
so my arms kind of hurt and then it's
like
i would say it's in my forearms and my
hands is it most intense in your arms
and hands
these muscles are so large yeah
those traps is it more in the shoulders
and traps or is it more in the arms
um it's probably in the shoulders okay
so let's just try something for a second
you can keep your eyes open or closed
but go to those shoulders when they're
in that kind of tense response
and ask them how old they think you are
oh i know how old they are right away
seven okay cool now when you're feeling
that fear at seven
where do you feel that angry part
probably solar plexus okay so let's go
there for a second and see if you can
feel that anger
too then ask the anger how old do you
think i am
that'd be 12. okay so almost teenager
right
got it yeah that's about that sounds
about right all right so ask the 12 year
old like what is it trying to keep you
safe from with all this anger
i think the anger is directed at the
medical system a lot of it
and i think i was diagnosed with
arthritis when i was seven
okay so it's angry because
i probably got hurt in there so they
hurt me they didn't take care of me
so when i was scared they didn't take
care of me
so in a lot of ways it's almost like i'm
going to be mad because i'm going to
take care of me now
because you can't does that seem right
yes okay ask the anger
if you if it knew that you had a self a
higher self or a soul self
or a self um an adult part of you um
that could take care of you what would
it rather be doing
with its time playing
yeah like outdoor playing yeah yeah but
i can't because i'll be scared
vulnerable and hurt again basically
is that what it thinks yeah yeah i like
that
that makes sense and how do you feel
towards that part when you think about
it being 12 and scared and arthritis and
the diagnosis and no one taking care of
you in the medical system like how do
you feel towards that part that's angry
sad
it's gonna make me cry and where do you
feel sadness
here for sure here okay so ask this
ask the throat and this that part how
old it thinks you are
maybe 17 so it's older like oh my god i
just want this to
stop yeah it's awful and how do you feel
towards that 17 year old
that's just sad sad yeah so it's the
same part the same sad part
yeah so check this out okay first of all
thank you for letting me
like actually have this this part of it
with you this is really scary
thank you for coming on and teaching me
about this so watch this for a second
okay
let's see if you can take that sad part
just for a moment we're not gonna get
rid of it
we understand it's sad it has really
good reasons to be sad
but imagine taking it and just bringing
it outside your body
two or three feet almost just like
you're holding it in front of you and
you see it
but it's not in here anymore it's right
here
so you're not getting rid of it you're
just kind of putting it over here
okay what's left after that sadness is
gone
i don't know i don't know
nothing clear so something that's not
clear
it definitely feels better yeah but
better like and
i bet that angry parts like this
[ __ ] what's going on right here
i don't know
can i trust it it's just an experiment
what would be left if the sadness was
gone in this area right here probably
relief
yeah that's nice right yeah yeah
and so how does that relief feel towards
the anger
i'm not feeling much of anything
emotional at the moment that's nice
so i don't know how come there's no
blase no no but that's actually a good
thing like the anger discharged how come
i have no idea let's go back to the
solar plexus and axe
ask it like where'd you go
you're 12 year old what happened i got
bored apparently
oh it sounds like i'll just kind of i'll
fast forward a little bit
what happened you had recognition and
i did not mean to make you cry i
apologize um but what you did is
we had recognition and then we actually
literally was called unblended from that
sadness
and we actually took it outside your
body just for a moment which actually
made you realize that there's something
else there which is just i just want
this relief
right and like that is a very valuable
way we're not going to take the sadness
and say [ __ ] off or drink it away or
travel away or get angry or whatever
we're just going to stay with it
and like a daily really great daily
practice could be like to sit with like
literally
hand here and on solar plexus like all
right guys like
tell me more and like let them kind of
be there and vent and then kind of
decide to kind of move them outside your
body and go what's left and the thing
about trauma work
is that we want to start to learn how to
make it safe to feel safe
because all these parts are trying to
keep us safe and drive and make [ __ ]
happen
it's like i can't trust me i have my own
medical system anger
as well because i did my mom but it's
like at the end of the day
the part of you that's intuitive and
feminine um
is going to be the part that's going to
keep you the most safe it's just that
the world when you were younger wasn't
able to keep that part safe and so it's
been like wrapped up in all these
different parts
and we can start to just kind of unblend
them a little bit and go what's left
and we have relief there it could be
scary to feel relief because there's
like something i have to defend against
still
but that's still usually typically that
anger that's like whoa
these [ __ ] aren't gonna take
care of me like what's going on here hey
yeah i got this now
by the way does that 12 year old know
how old you are now
i think i'm back at the age i'm supposed
to be i don't even feel the 12 year old
anything it's
so amazing right but what about the fear
in your shoulders
no it's still there a little bit but
it's definitely like i feel better
yeah that's really sneaky isn't that
cool yeah i mean it's not sneaky it's
it's cool i've been trying to learn ways
to like yeah it is that was very
efficient
and i was surprised about the like
it's interesting like put the emotion
outside and look at it so it's not
really like
stuffing it down and not looking at it
it's like remove it acknowledge it
that's right it's okay that you're
experiencing that that's right and when
you move something outside your body
you're depersonalizing it and you're
using your executive function neocortex
to look at it versus
being in your limbic system where it's
just kind of controlling you and it's
like it's like who you are
versus like it's out here and now i'm
looking at it so it's not who i am it's
what i'm looking at
and then you can observe it and give it
what it needed and typically
no dig on parents specifically but
typically every parent
has mistakes they've made but typically
when we have these things come up it's a
level of parenting that we didn't get
for whatever reason
right we didn't have that part
acknowledged or understood or taken care
of for whatever reason
um and so it's a really beautiful
re-parenting process and if you want
outside the podcast i'd be happy to
actually guide you through actual
process because this is like a very
brief process
of it so you can have like a more a
private experience of it obviously
but it's very it's very very simple and
efficient and you don't need to take
drugs
um and it's just it's just like turning
towards can be very valuable if you know
the process and so that's a
that's a little bit of parts work right
there that was really cool
okay awesome and i like that that's like
it's really it's
it's not exactly confronting it but it's
certainly not hiding and sometimes when
i know for me at least when i have these
emotions come up
i'm like i'm i don't want to be it's
like i don't want to be weak
so if i get scared or sad mostly i'm
like i don't want to be weak i'll get
angry instead
but then i've noticed and the older i've
gotten i've become more aware that like
you get sad you experience this if you
stuff it down it doesn't go away it's
just stuck somewhere and then you have
to experience it later or something
terrible happens like who knows but uh
it is better to like bring it up and
identify instead of running so yeah
and it actually it actually is the
opposite of weakness because if you
think about what makes something weak
it's usually
the more brittle or inflexible it is the
weaker it is when you can actually
surf your nervous system and understand
its responses and turn towards it you
actually create more emotional
pliability and flexibility which
actually makes you stronger
because you know look at tom brady right
like he's not ripped
in a in a traditional sense but the
dude's 44 and the most pliable dude on
the on the
on the turf because he works on his uh
physical pliability
like every single day that's why he
signs a four-year contract to like 48 or
whatever now right you win some
seven seven super bowls because he's so
pliable right so like
literally emotional flexibility
impliability is the opposite of weakness
it's just that in a very patriarchal
society showing emotion
um is perceived as weakness but that's
not what the neuroscience says
and the majority of the issues we're
having today are because people don't
know how to turn towards those feelings
and um on the other side of those
feelings is relief and wisdom and
intuition
and in your case probably a lot of
feminine energy that's looking for
expression in a different different way
um and that's uh that's like that's like
where all the good stuff is with the
play the fun and playing and fun are the
biochemical opposites of trauma
right um yeah and so there's other ways
to take care of those younger
traumatized parts besides anger and
anger by the way has a lot of efficacy
when you get angry there's some data to
suggest that if it's like
you have an angry while you finally get
angry it can actually start to stimulate
your immune system
so there is a value in that and
biochemically anger is an amphetamine
and it is an emotion of agency or power
um but it's not a great place to live
day to day because you will burn
out a lot of things um and the ventral
part the ventral vagal regulated self
the
self energy is actually a more competent
protector
um it's just a subtler energy to access
um but yeah that was really cool and
yeah i mean by the way you're a total
badass and this process is more just
about elevating that
um and it's cool that you're able to
actually like do this on a podcast like
people see it because i think
that's that's also a real leadership and
strength because a lot of people would
be like you know too cool for school or
too nervous but you're like nah let's
just try it which i think is like so
cool to lead by example
thank you thank you for showing me that
that was really interesting you've said
a couple of things during the podcast
that
remind me of things my dad has said like
one of them was
the importance of play was if you're
ever in a state of play or you're with a
group of people and you're all playing
that's like that's perfection
everyone's calm everyone's working
together like that's
heaven it is literally it's also the the
highest function
of uh of your nervous system like you're
using your most advanced parts
right your neocortex frontal lobe your
ventral vagal system your endorphin
system by the way the majority of our
opiate receptors are our prefrontal
cortex right so when we're feeling joy
and play and fun
that's like a neocortex higher vibration
because it's literally in the highest
form of our nervous system
um and you know when animals are playing
together they're cooperating and
thriving usually they're not in stress
and fear so 100 yeah cool
okay mastin thank you very much that was
fascinating
where can people they have well and you
came on super fast that was great i
learned a bunch
we will connect after yes where can
people find you
um just mastin kip m-a-s-t-i-n
dot com and then usually at mass and kip
on all the things
um and i spend most of my time on
instagram these days thinking about
getting on tick tocks i've been on tech
talk but actually utilizing it soon
um but massacre.com and at mass and camp
on all the all the sites
okay thank you very much my pleasure
you